if you want to buy this pair of Adidas
you can use your credit card or a buy
now pay later service
the result seems similar you don't pay
up front but with bnpl you can break
that full payment out into installments
usually with no interest by now pay
later firms have boomed over the last
three years and companies like PayPal
apple and credit cards themselves are
joining in on the hype but as some of
the companies scale up with their
growing customer base they're struggling
to turn a profit here's how buy now pay
later Services compare to credit cards
and what it means for the next time
you're checking out everything today is
pay as you go Dan delev is an analyst
who follows companies like affirm block
and PayPal credit is becoming a
pay-as-you-go thing especially in very
young Millennial demographics by now pay
later companies took off in the US
during the pandemic a firm the only bnpl
focused company that's public in the US
reported its Revenue more than doubled
over the last two years one of the main
ways these companies make money is
through Merchant discount rates a fee
the retailer pays to the company on each
buy now pay later purchase selling is
better than not selling and Merchants
are willing to accept somewhat of a
discount in order to make the sale the
number of retailers signed on to use a
firm jumped from just six thousand in
2020 to 235 000 in 2022 part of the
reason for its popularity is that by now
pay later is more accessible than a
credit card the npl is very attractive
to people who have credit difficulties
Todd Baker is a lecturer at Columbia Law
School who has worked as an executive in
finance and teaches about emerging
fintech other people do it just because
it seems like a good idea let's go back
to that cart with our Adidas with a
credit card you need approval to use
that credit often well before you put
your shoes in the cart companies like a
firm klarna and after pay on the other
hand can approve on the spot and make
approvals purchased by purchase that's
because of the different ways they check
your credit credit card companies do a
deep dive into your credit history that
shows up on your credit score by now pay
later companies typically perform a less
formal credit check and look at
additional data like previous times
you've used their service bnpl can give
more spending power to people who may
not have access to credit or have credit
build up but that can be an issue there
is a risk that credit will be extended
to you in a situation where you're not
likely to be able to repay and that's
not good either for the
issuer of the credit or for the consumer
a firm's CEO Max lepchin says the
company accounts for this we do have to
say no and tell our consumers with love
and compassion you're overextending
yourself please don't buy this klarna
says it also takes measures to make sure
it only extends loans to borrowers who
can repay both klarna and after pay
restrict use of their services if a
borrower misses a payment by now pay
later lacks some of the regulated
safeguards that credit cards have for
consumers in the U.S that's in part
because they're not covered by the truth
in Lending Act this is a law that
requires that lenders provide you all of
your loan information up front no hidden
costs it applies to loans that are paid
for in more than four installments by
now pay later Falls just below that the
product was structured essentially to
avoid the application of the the truth
and lending act the beauty of bnpl for
the retailers that's that it's
instantaneous and the provision of
significant disclosure before a
particular transaction would be very
difficult a firm says it provides a
truth and lending disclosure for all
credit extensions and clonis says it
supports additional regulation of the
sector the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau also warns that consumers could
risk over extension meaning they have
more debt than they can handle this
could happen because they could borrow
from multiple lenders at once since bnpl
platforms can't see borrowing activity
on other platforms
customer defaults when they happen can
have an impact on companies costs so
they have to balance the risk of
delinquencies with approving enough
transactions to cover their costs that's
the key to a successful buy now pay
later it's underwriting underwriting
underwriting
Corona said that its underwriting
practices have helped keep its default
rates below one percent but
delinquencies aren't the only thing that
can undermine profits
shifting consumer habits can cut down on
transactions and many buy now pay later
programs rely on funding that is
sensitive to interest rates since
Merchant fees make up the bulk of their
profit companies might have to raise
them to make up for higher borrowing
costs if interest rates go up a lot then
they're in trouble because the cost of
money is going to be too high to more
than offset with the merchant discount
rate a firm and karna offer services
Beyond bnpl and are continuing to
diversify their offerings but they're
also facing increasing competition from
Apple PayPal and credit card installment
plans still for some buy now pay later
CEOs like affirms levchin the
competition is clear the enemy or the
competitor is the credit cards not each
other despite these challenges the love
thinks that buy now pay later is here to
stay and as they become bigger and offer
more services they will be able to gain
scale and increase profitability but
some by now pay later firms like after
pay have been bought by larger companies
the fundamental question has always been
is bnpl a business or is it just a
product for other provider other
providers of financial services and I
think the consensus seems to be shifting
towards the idea that bnpl as a
standalone business is not likely to be
successful in the competitive market
foreign